Ursula it looks like it looks like you
brought your own hat rehearsal you did
why is that
[Applause]
so [ __ ] are always trying to
ice-skate uphill hyper one happy
comic-con week we got to talk about the
big blade reboot that Marvel just teased
so Kevin Feige just announced there's a
brand new version of blade coming to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe I'll explain
what's going on what happened with
Wesley Snipes when this is going to
happen and how this is going to
crossover with other Marvel movies we're
doing a giveaway for the Avengers
in-game blu-ray all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite blade moment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this so
we just broke this down top 7 style
starting with number 7 what just
happened Maher Sheila ollie was just
announced by Kevin Feige as the new
blade of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
most of you are like wait a minute isn't
he cottonmouth in the Luke Cage series
didn't they kill him off during that in
the first half of the season does that
mean that Luke Cage and the Netflix
shows are not connected to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they referenced a lot
of the events of Captain America Civil
War during the recent seasons of each of
those different shows
daredevil Luke Cage Jessica Jones even
iron fist but during the Marvel phase 4
panel they were announcing a bunch of
New Avengers MCU TV shows like Falcon
Captain America Winter Soldier in the
regular movies just to be clear blade is
getting a regular movie they have recast
the character and Wesley Snipes is no
longer going to be the main version of
blade Kevin Feige also revealed that
it's gonna take place during Marvel
phase 5 that's why the blade movie does
not appear on this Marvel phase 4
schedule because it won't be till after
2022 which is when Marvel phase 5 starts
per Kevin Feige
but right after the panel Wesley Snipes
issued a statement everyone was waiting
for him to react to the news like wait a
minute he wasn't on stage with them so
clearly he wasn't part of this how is he
gonna take it all or just read his
statement here he just reads to all the
daywalkers losing their minds right now
chillax
although the news comes as a surprise
it's all good such as the business of
entertainment much peace to the MCU crew
always a fan honor in respect to the
Grandmaster Stan Lee congratulations in
Salam 2 Maher Saleh Ali a beautiful
and talented artists whose expressions I
look forward to experiencing for many
years to come
inshallah we will someday work together
most importantly to my loyal fans the
incredible outpouring of love is
overwhelming I'm grateful for the
neverending support so not fret no worry
it's not the end of the story
welcome to the daywalker clique so
Wesley Snipes is just trying to let
everyone know that there's no bad blood
between him and Kevin Feige in the MCU
people for doing this new version of
blade but there have been rumblings
about a new blade project for several
years now so number six what happened to
Wesley Snipes he's been trying to get a
new blade project going for a while he'd
been pitching two blade projects to
Marvel Studios and Kevin Feige for quite
a long while since he started making
movies again the two projects he was
pitching though were a new blade movie
of course inside the Marvel Cinematic
Universe in a TV show focusing on blades
daughter like the series would have been
him mentoring his half vampire or 1/4
vampire daughter depending on who you
thought the mother was he even did an
interview a couple years ago back in
2017 talking about those clearly you can
see from the interview that he doesn't
know which way it's going to go there
was a little buzz about maybe a blade
for or maybe a TV series show likely
this is a possibility you know it's in
novels hands and they're controlling the
pace in there and the flow with that it
hurts a little bit to watch that like oh
yeah sure maybe I'll be part of the
Avengers clearly blade is meant to
crossover with the Avengers in this Numa
Hershel ollie version but number 5 why
did Kevin Feige recast blade with me
Hershel ollie instead of just doing
another movie with Wesley Snipes right
after this big Marvel phase 4 panel he
did an interview telling the story of
how this new blade movie was willed into
creation and what happened was is that
right after my Hershel ollie won his
second Oscar a little while ago he asked
for a meeting with Kevin Feige to talk
about Marvel projects typically they
don't take meetings with anybody that
just wants to take a meeting because
everybody wants to be in a Marvel movies
but because Maher shala Ally had just
won so many awards and was getting so
much positive attention from the press
Kevin Feige is like of course we'll take
a meeting with him but he said that when
he sat down in front of him in his
office he was like what do you want to
talk about what are you here for mahuri
lolly only says
one word he said blade and immediately
on the spot by he was like oh my god yes
green light go blade movie right now
let's do it
and we were talking very polite and he
was talking about what a fanny is and
then he just cut right to it and was
like blade and we're like yes
so clearly before their meeting happened
he didn't have any hot plans to make a
blade movie anytime soon his reasoning
was is that they were waiting for dr.
strange to come into the universe up to
a couple of years ago so they could do
more supernatural stories it was all
predicated on the existence of dr.
strange in his movie so now that they
have that all the other supernatural
characters you could think of that would
work well in movies like Ghost Rider or
Moon Knight are fair game right now
they're even making a Ghost Rider
spin-off TV show on Hulu with the actor
from agents of shield so I wouldn't
expect Ghost Rider in any of the movies
anytime soon which is kind of a bummer
but number four what about Wesley Snipes
best theory is is that Kevin Feige
wanted to go with a slightly younger
actor than Wesley Snipes so that he
could be blade for the next ten years or
so and he wouldn't look really really
old by the end of that even though right
now Wesley Snipes does look like he
could still play blade he doesn't look
like he's aged quite that much but also
if you've ever listened to the behind
the scenes of the making of blade
trinity patton oswalt
tells the funniest stories about how
difficult Wesley Snipes got during that
process I'm sure if you pressed Ryan
Reynolds enough he would tell similar
stories so whatever was going on behind
the scenes in the making of blade
Trinity Wesley Snipes just got a really
bad reputation for being difficult to
work with on set so fewer and fewer
studios were rushing to work with him on
really big projects he got into some
trouble but a long time has passed since
then so things may have changed but I
just think that Kevin Feige wants to do
a version of the blade character that
wholly originates from Marvel Studios
and doesn't have to deal with any of the
stuff that they did in the previous
blade movies like just treat that like
he's gonna treat the x-men movies it
happened in a different universe just a
completely separate thing and not part
of MCU canon but three that doesn't mean
that Wesley Snipes is completely out of
the picture so good news is Hershel
alley as a longtime fan of the blade
movies and Wesley Snipes like clearly he
loves the blade character that's why he
wanted to make a blade movie himself so
badly during the big panel at comic-con
he paid wesley snipes special tribute
clearly he has reverence for him and I
think it's pretty safe to assume that
when they actually get to making the
Blade movie it's only an early
development right now they'll bend over
backwards to find a role for wesley
snipes so I do think he'll be in that
new movie either as the new version of
Whistler or as another big character
regardless of how much screen time they
give him but to your other big question
how is this going to connect to the
other movies this will be connected to
the other Marvel phase 5 movies because
as Kevin Feige says it's not coming till
after Marvel phase 4 is over but how do
they explain vampires than the MCU have
they always been around and they just
haven't revealed themselves to the
Avengers so they'd like half of all
vampires get snapped after Avengers
infinity war and then half of them all
just came back after the Hulk snapped
everyone back that's how they're
planning on explaining the Eternals
characters which they also introduced
like Angelina Jolie and all these other
people in present day those eternals
characters exist they just haven't
announced themselves in the last hundred
years or so so nobody in present-day the
avengers characters the other MCU
characters just have no idea that they
exist
Feige mentioned Doctor Strange there's
going to be a doctor strange Scarlet
Witch multiverse team-up movie in a few
years during Marvel phase four that
movie is probably going to explain
everything you wanted to know about
supernatural characters like Ghost Rider
and vampires inside the MCU walking
around in present day the Blade movie
doesn't have a release date right now
but because it's not coming till after
Marvel phase four that means the
earliest we would possibly see it is
November 2022 or November 2023 I do
think that they're gonna release it
before they release the brand-new
Fantastic Four movie that they just
announced because they have their lead
actor now they just need a script and
they haven't cast any of the Fantastic
Four characters yet that we know of
number one though they haven't said who
the villain will be or which other MCU
characters are gonna cross over into the
new blade movie but this is really cool
Nick Palazzo creator of true detective
on HBO posted this reaction to the news
saying that he was jokingly bummed
because he wanted to do a moon night
series with Hershel alley if you didn't
watch true detective my Hershel ollie
was one of the stars of true detective
season 3 he did a good job but
wait for it his co-star was former blade
villain Stephen Dorff from the first
blade movie how about that it would also
be pretty cool if they brought him back
for a cameo in the new blade franchise -
most likely though the characters the
blade crosses over within the blade
movies in the MCU will be the darker MCU
characters Deadpool could be a good
match but post all your reactions in the
comments below now everybody's just like
let's get Moon Knight in a movie with
blade it'll be amazing they'll just
completely rip the screen up and
everybody will go crazy I'm working on a
new Thor for love and thunder video that
should post in the next day or so but
leave your requests in the comments
below
congratulations to Daniel Rodriguez
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details click here for my Marvel
phase for Comic Con teaser video and
click here for my breakdown of the Black
Widow Comic Con trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody to stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you